Hamlet has been having delusions, hallucinations,
anhedonia, lack of motivation, and poor speech.
He sees ghosts, and all of Denmark thinks
he’s crazy.
But, what is actually happening?
You, being the smarty-pants that you are,
diagnose him with schizophrenia.
Most people believe that schizophrenia is
caused by abnormal dopamine activity in the
brain.
Dopamine is a neurotransmitter that is expressed
in the central nervous system and regulates
things like motivation, cognition, emotions,
and the reward system.
Dopamine binds to dopamine receptors, which
are G-protein coupled receptors that are located
in the postsynaptic membrane.
This changes the structure of the receptor,
which can then activate a nearby G-protein
by exchanging the bounded GDP molecule for
a GTP molecule.
Once activated, the G-protein splits, with
its alpha subunit and the bound GTP moving
to bind to adenylyl cyclase.
The adenylyl cyclase is then activated, producing
cyclic AMP and spreading the signal throughout
the cell.
Schizophrenic patients have abnormal activity
at dopamine receptors, specifically D2 receptors,
with increased dopamine levels in the mesolimbic
area of the brain and decreased levels in
the prefrontal cortex.
Increased levels cause positive symptoms,
like hallucinations and delusions, while decreased
levels cause negative and cognitive symptoms,
like lack of motivation and decreased levels
of emotional expression.
Because the true cause of schizophrenia is
unclear, treatment aims to reduce symptoms
instead.
Antipsychotic drugs, specifically Risperidone,
binds to neurotransmitters like the D2 receptor
and inhibits dopamine from binding, which
alleviates positive, negative, and cognitive
symptoms.
However, treatment doesn’t always work.
Some are unresponsive to medication, most
drugs only reduce positive symptoms, not negative
or cognitive ones, and antipsychotics have
severe side effects.
And in general, schizophrenia prevents people
from leading normal lives.
They can’t form relationships or get an
education or job, and need constant support
to manage symptoms.
Therefore, social awareness is needed to help
those with schizophrenia.
Understanding schizophrenia can support patients
(especially ones with suicidal or unhealthy
lives), decrease rehospitalization and stigmatization,
monitor treatments, and bring them closer
to normal life.
And there we go!
How can you help Hamlet and others like him?